the Promenade at Morecambe Echoes to the
Heyday of the British Seaside where
people went to escape the worries of the
everyday where entertainers would sing
of bringing fun and bringing sunshine
how many people can forget those
everyday worries now
over two weeks we spent time with
families who live here like those all
over the country struggling and juggling
in a new economic climate it's not okay
you know things are not okay why is it
so hard it shouldn't have to be this
hard it's horrific it's affecting
everybody not knowing when it's going to
stop it's hard
what is the cost of the cost of living
crisis for families just trying to stay
afloat
it is down past the now demolished theme
park in morecambe's West End the
challenges are the most acute
the West End is home to Jasmine and her
daughters like millions of people their
morning routine is now full of anxiety
well obviously the fridge freeze has got
me on constantly
um the washing machine they're having to
turn off now but I'm not using it
um the cookers now turned off at the
wall but I'm not using it
the same with the microwave and the
airfryer well I first moved here I had
everything planned out like how much
each spill was going to cost and
everything else and now the Electric's
going up it's
kind of a pain because then I'm having
to take that money out of something else
and
obviously it's not going to come from
food even though that's going up so be
it my kids come fast at the end of the
day even for an eight-year-old like
Maisie Jasmine says the effects of the
cost of living crisis are being felt I
go I think she's starting to realize the
whole stress of everything as well
with me having to not fill the car up
and having to walk her to school and
stuff like that which as you hear that
she keeps going after I get the bus and
coming out on the bus I was like no you
got leg season you can walk to school
it's fine
it means a conversation millions of
parents are having with their children
see you later
she's starting to notice now that things
are starting to go up and that we're not
doing as much as we used to she's also
thinking well
why can some people do this but then
some people can't do this
especially when it gets to like certain
points in the month where payday is
coming up and
it sounds really bad but we're having to
use like mix and match of stuff that's
in the freezer just so I can empty it
and then fill it up again for the next
payday it's so stressful and it starts
playing on your head and you can't sleep
and then it affects your mental health
as well which is just it's horrible
in another more come home there are also
mouths to feed
foreign
live with their adult son plus pets
things that that weren't luxuries that
have now started to become luxuries like
like I said sometimes we'll have
breakfast late and then we'll have this
evening meal so we'll miss out having
lunch
which is not very diabetic friendly you
have to wait up the odds of diets and
not even medical diets as in because
you're diabetic are not poverty friendly
we will eat the cheap white bread
because it's the cheapest even though
it's not the best for our body it's it's
what we can afford
until we're possible we try and do one
pot cookery obviously some of the things
we need to use young Paul but we're
going to use the oven we're trying to do
as many things at the same time the
family rely on a benefit system not
keeping up with inflation it should go
up it should go up it's not in line with
the economy of today
is all I can say you know
um and I'm not the only one feeling the
pinch I think everybody Working Families
feel the pinch as well as people on the
benefits system I feel like I'm a
staying on Society for having to live on
benefits people think you just
comfortable handout
you know on the
and while don't get me wrong I
I know the government
have a lot of hard decisions to make I
don't doubt that for a minute but I feel
like
people look at you as if to say well if
we didn't have to pay for your benefits
then the economy would be in a better
position
um
but they don't understand how poverty
and living below the poverty line
affects people's General Health we feel
like we're Oliver Twist kind of scenario
you know begging bull
foreign
spends his days literally putting roofs
over the heads of families once you pass
that to Joe will you start from the
other side checking for nails mate his
own hopes of getting his foot on the
property ladder though have been ripped
from under him by the chaos in the
mortgage Market found a nice three-bed
Terrace in morecam uh perfect uh for
where I where I was looking for right uh
right smack bang in the Middle where all
my family are uh put the offer in been
accepted
uh it was all going through quite quite
smoothly and then um
they've sort of retracted the original
offer was a API rate of I think it was
about 6.5 uh and obviously the mortgage
repayments were around 650 pound a month
second after they come back at me with
it was 8.6 and mortgage repayments of
700 and 80 pound a month maybe even
closer to the 800 pound Mark I think but
uh it's just it's just not it's not it's
not it's not fair really I don't think
but like I said start my control just
plainly play it was quite heartbreaking
like I said I've been I've been there
saving up for a mortgage for best part
five six years maybe more
fried them off you'd have to do as much
walking on the Roof then
as for so many people this crisis has
changed how she lives her life
we try and go around to friends houses
in the mornings just to
obviously not be on our own as well but
to try and save electric so we're not
having to use any of it so it's not so
bad but
it's still extortionate
a lot of my friends try not to talk
about it because
as much as they are strong-willed they
try not to let it show that they're
struggling
um
it's got to the point where
If you're sort of doing what you need to
do to feed the kids some whatever else
my friends are having to borrow more
from their friends and family than what
they've ever had to which is the same
case for me as well
for Louise getting out of the house is
essential even if it is no escape from
the financial stresses
look at all the garages look at
Sainsbury's look at Morrisons look at
Asda and whoever's got the cheapest
price for the day is where I will go to
get some petrol and then I will phone
around family and friends and let them
know what price it is where I've been
just in case they're needing any petrol
so that they can take advantage of the
lower price from that area
in the heart of morecombe's West End the
Stanley Center has become a Lifeline
both physically
and emotionally things to do
people to look after
the numbers at the weekly meditation
sessions have grown
we'll Circle back now to the three
points we started with
you take away people's dignity and you
take away people's Security in the sense
of you know being able to pay for bills
being able to heat the houses you take
away their um the most important thing
they have which is their peace of mind
it includes all of us because a lot of
professionals are now a you know are
really struggling under the pressure of
of what's happening because we're taking
away all of the points of safety from
people you're not going home and and
just forgetting the world actually a
home has become
um a bit of an enemy because it's just
creating so many problems for creating
bills that you just can't possibly pay
we're offering places of Refuge that
aren't trying to fix you and Aren't
trying to say don't worry it's okay
because it's not okay it's not okay you
know things are not okay we've been
going 10 years and I've never known
people this desperate
in the room next door it all dominates
the brew and chat it is affecting every
you know everybody
this year has just been absolutely
exceptional
the need is increasing at a far
higher rate than I thought possible I
had a 92 year old man two weeks ago who
went out into his garden and shouted for
help obviously got no food
it's not something I want to deal with
it's horrific it's affecting everybody
and there's a lot of people very very
proud in this area that won't ask for
help
well done you got it
without that house of his own for roofer
Chris home life is now with his sister
and her family there we go
I love him to face it I love living with
him but at the same time she's trying to
grow a family expand to expand and say
I'm trying to do the same obviously the
only thing called him is back is the
financial situations and obviously I'm
not the only person to be affected by it
everybody's in a similar sort of
situation but it's just it's getting to
the point where nothing's becoming
nothing's possible they must know that
it's not not affordable for people in my
position to for what they're what
they're offering it's all come crashing
down yeah she's got the two young kids
that are only needing more space every
day and
sort of uh I'm feeling like I'm getting
in the way now it's not a nice feeling
really but it's a rolling we're all
feeling the same so
on the other side there's a swirling
Whirly
all over the country there are people
living life in a way they never expected
if you look there are those trying to
defy the odds
in what was once a church a father and
son betting on a new micro bar people
always find money to spend on themselves
even during in fact times of hardship we
just got to remember with our prices to
make sure that obviously we hit the
right market we've got a good plan for
the next couple of years here and where
we want to be the things that we want to
achieve the numbers that we want to hit
and we will work our socks off to get
there and it's the only thing that will
that will make it happen look's not
going to make this place work you know
we've we've planned it down you know to
the last Heat to the last screw that's
got in the wall and we're absolutely
raring to go just hoping hoping it's
busy enough
[Music]
[Laughter]
and for parents like Jasmine trying to
insulate their children completely is
impossible this is eight-year-old
maisie's View
toys are spun up
these shoes are gone up as well clothes
gone up as well bags are gonna
like it's all the payment of everything
has just gone high up if it was like
three pounds something like three pounds
fifty like um a little coat for
um my sister and she had three pound
fifty I really like you can't buy
anything else because she has no money
money
do you want me to cut this up for you
yeah
it takes its toll so
from a parent's point of view you sort
of have to put this face on so like
nothing's facing you you're all fine
everything else and like the minute the
kids go to bed you're like
because that was odd
why is it so hard it shouldn't have to
be this hard my two pound lottery ticket
I'm forever praising the Lord not
unbelievable please let me win please
let me win just so that I can have be
comfortable I don't want to be rich I
want to be comfortable
and as for that new bar coffee is
officially open
[Music]
going wrong
obviously you've got to keep our heads
down and crack on
it is a plan a hope for the future
in Morecambe in towns and cities
communities and families all over the
country hope is all many can do